الى المزيد من التحليل العسكري ينضم الينا
الان من عمان اللواء فايزه دويريا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا دعنا
نبدا بهذا الهجوم على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اكياس هجوم جوي اذا روسي غير مسبوق كما
وصف من حيث الكثافه التنوع ايضا ما الذي
قد يبرزه ذلك ان اردنا الحديث والتركيز
على الامكانيات الروسيه في هذه المرحله
يعني اولا
كييف هي مركز الثقل
الاستراتيجي في ابعاده السياسيه والعسكريه
والامنيه وما شابه ذلك وبالتالي سيكون على
قائمه اولويه اهداف الجيش الروسي هذا
الهجوم جاء تقريبا بعد عده ايام من هجوم
مماثل ولكن ذلك الهجوم استخدمت فيه
الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه كنجال بصوره اوسع
واشمل ودار الحديث عن اسقاط سته صواريخ
وما شابه ذلك والحاق اضرار في بطاريه
اذا دعني اقول هذه الفتره هي فتره تصعيد
بكل ما في الكلمه من معنى من الجانب
الروسي ومن الجانب الاوكراني وكلا
الجانبين يسعى لتحقيق اهدافه الجانب
الروسي يسعى الى اكتشاف نقاط الضعف ونقاط
القوه من اجل استغلال نقاط الضعف ومحاوله
السفير على القوه خاصه فيما يتعلق
بمنظومات الدفاع الجوي المتعدده نحن لا
نتحدث هنا عن بطاريتي باتريوت باك 3 لكن
نتحدث عن العديد وطيف واسع من الدفاعات
الجويه سواء الامريكيه او الغربيه يقابل
ذلك هناك تصعيد من الجانب الاوكراني هذا
التصعيد يطال طرق الامداد وشبكات الامداد
وترجم فعليا باخراج قطار عن عمله في شبه
جزيره القرم التي تعتبر الشريان الرئيسي
لادامه المعركه يضاف الى ذلك تصعيد في
باخموت من الطرفين الجانب الروسي يحاول
استكمال السيطره الجانب الاوكراني يخوض
معركه معاكسه خطيره جدا اذا نجحت وهي بدا
الحديث عن السيطره على عشرين كيلو متر
مربع في منطقه الشولدرز او الاكتاف
الدفاعيه
مدينه باخموت اذا ما حقق الخطه بصوره جيده
فهذا سيقلب الموازين في وسط دومباس
وستتمكن القوات الاوكرانيه من اجراء عمليه
تطوير واجبار القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب
مما يغير في مقاربه هجوم الربيع المنتظر
بخصوص طبعا روسيا تركز قصفها هناك
والعمليه تستمر منذ شهور لقطع الامداد على
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تعتبرها حصن منيع
بخموت لكن كيف ترى تطورات الوضع هناك مع
استماته الطرفين في هذه المعركه
يعني الان القوات الروسيه ركزت على
الشريان الحيوي وقامت بتدمير الجسر قبل
اسبوعين ظنا منها انها تستطيع ان تقطع
الامداد عن القوات
المتواجده في اخر جيم ولكن القوات
الاوكرانيه تعتمد على استخدام ما يسمى
المرور عبر الضواحي المرور من خلال
المناطق على غير غير لا يوجد فيها طرق
سواء معبده او ترابي ولكنها تسمى تنكب
الايريا المناطق التي يمكن استخدامها من
قبل الاليات العسكريه وتمكنت من ايصال
المعدات
والقوه اللازمه للدعم لا بل تمكنت استنادا
الى التصريحات الاوكرانيه والى حديث
بريجوجل وكلاهما يلتقي رغم اختلافهم حول
مقدار النجاح ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تمكنت من شن هجوم في الجانب الايمن
جانب الايسر وحققت نجاحات في كل الجانبين
ولا تزال تتقدم من اجل تطويق مدينه
واستعاده السيطره الكليه عليها
نشكرك كنت معنا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي